hello everyone that was brunch them was
a renowned chess author and while his
book the Zurich international tournament
of 1953 is regarded as one of the
greatest chess books ever written as
well international masters said that
after they read this book they felt
their chests rank really improved as
Bernstein's comments in this book are
well they're amazing so if if you're
looking to improve your game you know
feel free to acquire the book the Zurich
international tournament of 1953 as I've
heard only praises about this book and
well there's a lot of talk about the
strongest chess players who never became
world champion but that was branched and
it really might be the strongest player
who never became world champion as he
did when the candidates tournament in
1950 and he did challenge Mikhail
Botvinnik for the title in 1951 and well
he was this close to winning the to
winning the title of the match ended in
a draw they each won five games and 14
games were drawn so yeah I mean I don't
believe he came the closest to becoming
world champion but this game I have
prepared for you today was played in
1954 and this is the match Argentina
versus the Soviet Union this is round
one and on board one David Bronstein is
facing me on I Dorf and well it's always
a treat when a night off goes for the
night or variation and one other reason
this is one of my favourite Bronstein
games is I actually used this idea
Bronstein had in this game to win a
couple of my games so let's see this
game and well a Broxton was also known
for thinking quite a lot even before
making the first move he sometimes he
used like 15 to 20 minutes before even
playing the first move so let's see this
game we have a four by Bronstein and C 5
by night off the Sicilian defense we
have Knight to f3 d6 we have d4 see
captors on d4 Knight captures and e4 and
Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 and neither of war
goes for the knight of variation a6
we have Bishop to g5 we have P 6 and
here branch line plays Queen to f3 and
this is this
well famous line although Queen to f3
was the main theory back then but today
well in this position if you saw my
previous video played by Davi Navarra
he played f4 and this game is the reason
why f-4s played today
so branch tangos Queen to f3 and we have
Knight B to d7 by night off we have
queenside castle and now Queen to c7 and
here
well Gary Kasparov in his book my great
predecessors says that it took branch
958 minutes to make his next move and
after thinking for 58 minutes he played
the Queen to g3 and well it's exactly
this is the exact position why I said
that f4 was played in it's now played in
that position
because now black has the option of
playing h6 here and because the Queen is
now on g3 Bishop to h4 is no longer
possible because g5 wins the piece here
so after this h6 move now White has to
decide whether he will grab the grab the
knight on f6 here or he will retreat
with the Bishop to e3 for example but
after he retreats the e3 b5 is
completely fine for black but after this
branch lines 58 minute move Queen to g3
knight or simply continued to play like
it was a normal night of variation and
he played B 5 and now branch Tang
executes his idea that he had and it it
it's also said that branch line took
like 40 minutes for his next move
he played Bishop captures on b5 so the
idea behind this move is he will
sacrifice his piece well he will grab
two pawns for it and even three and he
will be left with a three passed pawns
here a B and C pawn so we have a capture
some b5 and now Knight D capture some b5
attacking the Queen and also the d6 pawn
and this was the idea of Queen to g3 now
the Queen is also attacking the d6
square
we have a queen to b8 and now Knight
captures an d6 and this is what check we
have Bishop captures and d6 and now
Queen captures and b6 brush and
sacrificed a piece but he also wants to
exchange Queens so we have Queen
captures and e6 and rook captures and e6
and ok night off has a piece but this
three past points are very strong and
probably most players will will prefer
to be white in this position so we have
age 6 by Bronstein and perhaps it was
because of this h6 move that the branch
I was thinking for so long whether he
should or should not go into this
variation because there were games
played in this variation before and
while Bishop captures and f6 was played
and this is branch lines real
contribution to this game he played
Bishop to d2 so after this move Knight
off played Bishop d7 attacking the e4
pawn we have f3 and already this is very
nice a very nice pawn structure for
white here this is unbreakable for the
moment and here knight of castle and I
actually I actually had this exit in
this exact position in one of my games
and my opponent played King to e7 here
which is the stronger moved and the one
neither of played as it's a it's a very
weird idea why White Castle here I mean
King 37 this is the endgame the King
belongs in the center of the board he
will be it will be helping out his pawns
and pieces here on g8 he is really not
going to do that much but ok after f3
Knight of castled and we have b3 rook F
to c8 and King Tubby - I will Knight to
c5 and now Bishop to e3 attacking that
night and c5 we have E 5 neither of his
creating an outpost for his knight and
e6 so he can jump to d4 or f4 depending
on what branched in place we have rook H
2 d1
Knights the e6 by night off and now rook
to b6 attacking the bishop on b7
Bishop to c6 and now Knight to d5 and
now branchton is a threatening nice day
seven would check capturing the rook or
if the rook moves even capturing this
bishop that is already attacked by the
rook so neither of kept it captures the
knight Bishop captures on d5 and we have
it captures on d5 and now neither of now
Bronstein creates another pass pawn and
now he has four connected passed pawns
and this is well this is certainly worth
the piece we at night to see five and
now first rook to b5 attacking the
knight twice we have night after d7
defending and now c4 and looking look at
this beautiful point chain it stretches
across half the board and well this is
very hard now to play for nine Dorf we
have efore Bishop captures on c5 Knight
captures on c5 and F captures any four
and here knife captors and E for and
well in this position the strongest move
for branchton would probably would be
something like a four maybe but
burnished and played d6 and he'll I was
neither of a small tactic that will
require bunch tend to play a bit more
accurately as he played rook captures
and a2 would check now King captures an
a2 and now Knight to c3 with check for
King the king and the rook
so King to a3 and now Knight captures
and d1 and okay c5 and well it's still
winning for white but you do have to
play it precisely it's you know always
better to have an extra pawn on da file
so Knight to c3 attacking the rook rook
to a five and we have Knight to d5 and
here branch then pushes c6 and well this
is this is a this is an excellent move
as well but can't really play a real
captures on c6 and rook captures on d5
as there is well this is a completely
winning endgame for white so this
resource is out of the question
so after c6 he played rooked Knight to
f6 and now we have worked a six
defending that pawn we have King to f8
before King - 8b v now the c6 pawn is
protected nice to d7 and here in I
prefer gets an idea
that he would like to sacrifice his own
piece and in return that he will have
some drawing chances and well neither
this isn't really that bad of a move
after see catheters 97 in kink after
sandy 7 white is only a pawn up and well
probably still winning but again you
would have to play this very precisely
but there was no need for this
after this Knight to d7 move branched
and simply played rook to a 7 now there
is a thread of of course he captures on
d7 would check so rock the BA displayed
now we have worked the rookie after 77
rocky after some b5 we had rocked the a7
threatening Roque to checkmate
so rook to b8 is played and now d7 check
and this wins the game immediately if if
King goes to d8 then simply c7 wins the
rook so we have King to e7
and now pawn to d8 promoting to a queen
with a double check from the Queen and
the rook King captor sandy 8 and now c7
and this is a check and also attacking
the black rook so in this position
McGill night of resigned and branch then
I want this brilliant game so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank David focus for
your contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it thank you a lot sir and
yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon